♪ ♪
>> Sean: TONIGHT, FLORIDA
REPUBLICANS, THEY ARE FOLLOWING
THROUGH ON THEIR PROMISES
TONIGHT AS THE STATE SENATE IN
FLORIDA PASSED A NEW BILL TO
STRIP DISNEY OF ITS
SELF-GOVERNING STATUS AFTER THE
COMPANY'S LIES AND SMEARS
AGAINST THE STATE'S NEW PARENTAL
RIGHTS IN EDUCATION LAW.
THE BILL NOW MOVES TO THE
FLORIDA HOUSE.
GOVERNOR RON DeSANTIS ADDED
THAT HE DOESN'T SUPPORT SPECIAL
PRIVILEGES JUST BECAUSE A
COMPANY IS BIG AND POWERFUL.
ASK YOURSELF, WHY SHOULD DISNEY
ENJOY SPECIAL AND GENEROUS
STATUS, ESPECIALLY WHEN THEY
CONTINUE TO AMPLIFY LIES,
ATTACKED CONSERVATIVES.
ANYWAY, HERE WITH REACTION,
FORMER FLORIDA ATTORNEY GENERAL
PAM BONDI, ALONG WITH THE ONE
AND ONLY FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR,
LEO 2.0 TERRELL L.
ALL RIGHT, SO THIS JUST
DISSOLVES THE SPECIAL
SELF-GOVERNING STATUS GIVEN TO
DISNEY 50 YEARS AGO, PAM.
YOU ARE FROM FLORIDA, THEY
GOT IT IN THE FIRST PLACE, WHY
WASN'T IT STRIPPED ALONG TIME
AGO.
WHY DID THEY GET SOMETHING THAT
NOBODY ELSE GETS IN THE STATE?
>> EXACTLY, SEAN.
YOU KNOW, THEY MANAGED TO
BASICALLY FLY UNDER THE RADAR
FOR A VERY LONG TIME.
THIS WAS ESTABLISHED 55 YEARS
AGO, WHEN THE COUNTY WHERE
DISNEY WAS BUILT DIDN'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO REALLY HELP THEM,
SO THEY GOT ALL THESE SPECIAL
ENTITLEMENTS, BUT THEY HAVE
CONTINUED TO HOLD ONTO THEM FOR
55 YEARS.
I SPOKE TO WILTON SIMPSON
TONIGHT, OUR GREAT SENATE
PRESIDENT, A GOOD FRIEND OF
MINE, AND HE WILL BE OUR NEXT
AGRICULTURAL COMMISSIONER IN
FLORIDA.
WILTON MADE A REALLY GOOD POINT.
HE SAID THE PARENTAL RIGHTS LAW
IN FLORIDA, IT'S ABOUT
PROTECTING CHILDREN AND PARENTS
RIGHTS FROM NOT HAVING FIVE,
SIX, SEVEN, AND 8-YEAR-OLDS TALK
TO ABOUT SEX, PERIOD.
THAT IS WHAT IT IS ABOUT,
PROTECTING WHAT PARENTS WANT IN
THE STATE OF FLORIDA, AND DISNEY
CHOSE TO WADE INTO THE POLITICAL
DEBATE AND NOW THEY ARE IN IT
AND THEY ARE IN IT AND THEY ARE
NOT GOING TO GET OUT OF IT.
BIG MISTAKE ON THEIR PART,
BECAUSE THEY ARE ABOUT TO GET
ALL OF THEIR SPECIAL
ENTITLEMENTS TAKEN AWAY.
IT WILL PASS THE SENATE, PAST
THE HOUSE ON FINAL READINGS
TOMORROW AND RON DeSANTIS IS
GOING TO SIGN THAT LAW.
>> Sean: LEO 2.0 TERRELL, WILL
DISNEY CLAIM THIS IS A
CONSTITUTIONAL FREE-SPEECH ISSUE
AND THEY ARE BEING PENALIZED FOR
IT?
OR WILL THE STATE'S ARGUMENT
THAT YOU DON'T DESERVE SPECIAL
STATUS WHEN OUT?
>> I CAN TELL YOU RIGHT NOW, AND
PAM SUMMARIZED DISNEY'S
POSITION, DISNEY FREE-SPEECH IS
OUT THERE OUT IN THE OPEN.
THEY LIED ABOUT THIS BILL.
THIS WAS A PARENTAL RIGHT BILL.
THE MOUSE HAS BEEN CAUGHT, AND
THEREFORE, THE FLORIDA STATE
LEGISLATURE HAS THE RIGHT TO
GRANT THIS LEGISLATION TO STRIP
AWAY THE SPECIAL PRIVILEGES.
LET'S BE VERY CLEAR,
RON DeSANTIS AND THE FLORIDA
STATE LEGISLATURE, THEY HAVE A
BACKBONE.
THEY ARE BASICALLY SENDING A
MESSAGE TO ALL THESE WOKE
CORPORATIONS THAT YOU CANNOT
DICTATE POLICY TO THE PEOPLE OF
FLORIDA.
I AM VERY PROUD OF THE STATE OF
FLORIDA BECAUSE THEY ARE
BASICALLY SENDING A SIGNAL TO
ALL THESE CORPORATIONS, AND
JEN PSAKI, THOSE CROCODILE
TEARS, JUST ABSOLUTELY LYING
ABOUT THE NATURE OF THIS BILL.
FINAL POINT, I WAS A
SCHOOLTEACHER.
I STILL HAVE MY LICENSE.
AND PAM IS SPOT ON.
THIS IS A BILL TO PROTECT
PARENTS RIGHTS OVER THEIR OWN
CHILDREN.
NOT FOR THE STATE AND NOT FOR
DISNEY TO CONTROL OR
INDOCTRINATE CHILDREN.
>> Sean: HAVE ABOUT 45
SECONDS, PAM, DO YOU BELIEVE
THAT DISNEY WILL CHALLENGE THIS
IN THE COURTS AND IF THEY DO,
WHAT WILL THE RESULT BE?
>> THEY MAY CHALLENGE IT.
THEY WILL NOT BE SUCCESSFUL.
DISNEY CHOSE TO WADE INTO THIS
DEBATE.
THESE LIBERAL ELITIST, INSTEAD
OF STAYING IN THEIR LANE, WHICH
IS WHAT, ENTERTAINING
FAMILIES, MAKING A LOT OF MONEY
FOR THEIR SHAREHOLDERS, BUT
INSTEAD, THEY DECIDED TO ATTACK
THE STATE OF FLORIDA.
THEY ARE THE ONES WHO SAID, WE
ARE GOING TO FIGHT THIS LAW, WE
ARE GOING TO GET THIS LAW
OVERTURNED, SO THEY FIT THIS
FIGHT AND THEY ARE GOING TO LOSE
THIS FIGHT, SEAN.
>> Sean: TO ME, IT IS JUST
LIKE THE NFL, STAY OUT OF
POLITICS, PEOPLE OF ALL
BACKGROUNDS, EVERYBODY WITH A
SHARED PASSION, EVERYBODY THERE
WITH A SHARED PASSION, TO HAVE A
MAGICAL DAY, YOU HAVE TO
RUIN IT WITH POLITICS, WHEN
PEOPLE SHOULD BE HAVING FUN, NOT